you directed this film and you're also
in the film starring in the film do you
ever put you in an odd position I would
think where you're looking at scenes
afterwards and you know the scene may be
pretty good but you may not like the way
you look in the scene and as the
director you may be biased and and use
another take dude I'm saying absolutely
but I actually brought a clip of a
moment that that couldn't be used in the
movie we were shooting a scene that was
supposed to be in rain and it started
raining and so we jumped to shoot the
scene in the rain so that we wouldn't
have to use a rain machine we just
didn't take into consideration how
strong the winds were during this storm
and so this is un Breckin Meyer and I
were you in mind where we're smoking
outside in it with an umbrella and in a
middle of a rainstorm and I brought this
clip just because the wind the wind took
this umbrella and and hit me square in
the face while we were doing it yeah the
wind just sort of tasty umbrella and RAM
right down on top of you yeah and I have
to say I was really proud of myself
because I could tell the thing was
coming if you if you play it again you
see me you see me not only lean into the
hit and turn my face so that it makes
contact with my hairline but I actually
got both of my hands on the pole yeah to
try and control it as it went down and
so I had just like turned my head just
enough to make sure that the injury
would be in my hairline and then we kept
shooting because that's what you do
that was done well you just make
something incredibly dorky sound heroic
well I really did but I managed to save
the shot and maybe I got a shot at Bob
Saget's grand prize yeah exactly we have
a clip here from change land anything
you want to tell us about this scene yes
I will give you so um in the movie my
buddy Dan and I go on this adventure
that was supposed to be a second
honeymoon my character finds out his
wife's been having an affair and instead
of confronting or takes this trip with
his old best friend to figure out what
to do we get into a series of adventures
and meet a bunch of cool characters and
in this scene I found my way into a muy
Thai boxing ring with somebody who I
don't think is really fighting me I
think it's all like for fun and Brecon
who plays dan is giving me advice on how
not to die yeah I'm the ring because it
turns out the guy is taking a fight yeah
well he forewarned me and I just didn't
believe him yeah here's a clip from
change land main thing is you're just
letting him hit you okay you want to
avoid that as much as possible okay
because he's certain you really hard and
there's only so much you can take before
you actually die all right so main
takeaway don't get hit
Hey are we fighting like for real
I hear you but not a guy not a knows how
to fight listen anything not a guy who's
ever been in a fight a guy who has never
been in a fight before it says punch
time he punches just giving himself
motivation yeah very nice the movie
change land is on video on demand and in
select theaters right now and you should
check it out Seth Green congratulations
really good to see
[Applause]